what's up king and the sting
theo you look like the second most
successful person in your trailer park
and brendan you look like the least
amount of effort
someone has to go through to fill a
diversity quota
i've got a debate it's about letting
people
in on what's going on in your life you
see i'm a quadriplegic paralyzed in the
collarbone down
and i also have debilitating chronic
nerve pain
so i want to let people know if i'm
hurting but i don't want to feel pity
and i don't want people to stop
asking me to do things so my question to
both of you
is how much do you let people in on
what's going on in your life
damn brother gang gang short buzz
gang homie wrong bro how should he do it
deal let him know that he's certain
yeah i just you just tell them [ __ ]
what's going on man theo tells people
about it on the podcast
yeah yeah i i mean my goal is really
tell hundreds of thousands of people at
once
that way you only have to say it once
though it's smart yeah
that's true you need to start a tick
tock you start his tick-tock he tells
how people he feels every he starts his
tick tock in the mornings dancing
that's interesting those go really viral
too like a lot of people with who have
um disabilities and
there's a lot of blind and deaf humor on
tick tock which is
it's fun i think it's hilarious but like
blind and i think i gave you one of
those nick but like a lot of blind and
deaf people
have gone viral because good for them
yeah yeah good for them break my arm
chin
what are we gonna say i think if you um
you know i got caught into some weird
circles on the tick tock i get a lot of
down syndrome
and d ass family because they think
you're the team captain
uh no i'm just i don't know how i got in
the loop but
like maybe
no he's probably on their explorer page
but no they yeah something happened
where i just get a lot of i'm in the ds
family hashtag
but i get a lot of it so i follow you
know i'm into six or seven people's
lives on there you see what's going on
but and i really enjoy you start to
learn about what it's like to have it
you know really fully have it and um
what else man i think yeah
it's tough to let people know what's
going on but also not to sound like you
want them to feel sorry for you bro it's
a tough walk bro
um i don't know what's the best way to
do it man
i think just share it but also just know
for yourself that you gotta
you know you gotta pick you gotta pick
up your own pieces like in the end it's
okay to share it and like ask for help
but
you also you gotta have some methods of
your own to pick up your own pieces
it sounds like you do you got a great
sense of humor you know you can't even
you know you can't even move some things
on your body and you calling in and
[ __ ] calling us
out uh yeah he has a great attitude
maybe get like
a [ __ ] sharpie thing and like draw
like scale one to ten how you feeling
that day
wait i'm confused he's paralyzed from
the collarbone down he said but his arms
work that's what i was thinking too
from the sea nerve oh someone is just
his upper body then right it's like
yeah that's all you need i'll be
sometime
probably some woman got on his nerves
literally got on his nerves yes yeah of
course brendan
[Laughter]
did you think there was a small woman
living on his central nervous system
but i don't know what do you do i mean
what do you guys do if you you know it's
tough to these days i feel like
you know ask for help but not try to
sound all the time like the boy who
cried wolf you know it's tough yeah
i think i let people know so you just
don't seem like an [ __ ] all the time
if you're in pain
yeah people know man like you said this
guy seems like he knows what's going on
you just got to read the room so people
are like how are you doing and you just
don't want to unload on someone
some pass or buy in the street but it's
okay to be like not good dude not
[ __ ] good
how about that it's okay to say that
is